i can ask you a ridiculous question sure
can i give a ridiculous answer
uh do you think uh
well maybe by way of asking the question
let me first mention that you're kind of
critical of the idea of the touring test
as a test of intelligence
let me first ask this question
do you think we'll be able to build
an ai system
that humans fall in love with and it
falls in love with the human
like romantic love
but we've had that with humans falling
in love with cars even back in the 50s
it's a different love right well i think
i think there's a lifelong partnership
where you uh
can communicate and grow like
i think we're a long way from that
i think we're a long long way i think um
uh
blade runner was you know had the time
scale totally wrong
yeah but
do you so uh
to me honestly the most difficult part
is the thing that you said with the
marvex paradox is to create a human form
that interacts and precedes the world
but if we just look at a voice
like the movie her or just like an alexa
type voice
i tend to think we're not that far away
well for some for some people maybe not
but i i
you know i i
you know as humans as we think about the
future we always try to
and this is the premise of most science
fiction movies you've got the world
justices today and you change one thing
right but that's not how and it's the
same with a self-driving car you change
one thing no you everything changes yes
everything
grows together so surprisingly i might
be surprising to you or might not i
think the best movie about this stuff
was bicentennial man
and what was happening there um it was
schmaltzy and you know but what was
happening there
as the robot was trying to become more
human
the humans were adopting the technology
of the robot and changing their bodies
yeah so there was a convergence
happening
in a sense
so we will not be the same you know
we're already talking about uh
genetically modifying our babies you
know there's a
there's
more and more stuff happening around
that
we will we will want to modify ourselves
even more for all sorts of
things um
we put uh all sorts of technology in our
bodies um to improve it you know
i've got
i've got things in my ears so that i can
sort of hear you yeah
yeah so we're always modifying our
bodies so
so you know i think it's hard to imagine
exactly what it would be like in the
future
but on the turin test side
do you think uh so forget about love for
a second
let's talk about just uh like the elect
surprise actually i was invited to be uh
what is the interviewer for the alexa
prize or whatever um
that's in two days
their idea is uh
success looks like a person wanting to
talk to an ai system for a prolonged
period of time like 20 minutes
how far away are we
and why is it difficult to build an ai
system with which you'd want to have a
beer and talk for an hour or two hours
like
not for to check the weather or to check
music but just like to
uh to talk as friends yeah well you know
we saw we saw um weisenbaum uh back in
the 60s with his programmer eliza um
being shocked at how much people would
talk to eliza and i i remember you know
in the 70s typing you know stuff to
eliza see what it would come back with
um
you know i think right now
and
this is the thing that um
uh
amazon's been trying to improve with
alexa there is no continuity of of a
topic
does not
you can't refer to what we talked about
yesterday um it's not the same as
talking to a person where this seems to
be an ongoing existence right changes
um we share moments together and they
last in our memory together yeah and
there's none of that and there's no
um
sort of intention of these systems that
they have any
goal in life even if it's to be happy
you know they don't they don't
even have a semblance of that now i'm
not saying this can't be done i'm just
saying i think this is why we don't feel
that way
about them well that's a that's a a i'm
sort of a minimal requirement if you
want the sort of
interaction you're talking about it's a
minimal requirement whether it's going
to be sufficient
i don't know
we haven't seen it yet we don't know
what it
feels like i tend to be i tend to think
it's uh it's not
as difficult as solving intelligence for
example
and uh i think it's achievable in the
near term
but on the touring test
why don't you think the turing test is a
good test of intelligence oh i i because
you know
again the turing if you read the paper
turing wasn't saying this is a good test
he was using as a rhetorical device to
argue um
that if you can't tell the difference
between a computer and a person you must
say that the computer's thinking because
can't tell the difference you know
when it's thinking you can't you can't
say something different
um what it has become as this sort of
weird game of fooling people um
so
back at the
uh ai lab in the late 80s we had this
thing that still goes on called the ai
olympics and one of the events we had
one year
was um
the original imitation game as turing
talked about because he starts by saying
can you tell whether it's a man or a
woman
so we did that at the at the lab we had
you know you'd go and type and
the thing would
come back and you had to tell whether it
was a man or a woman um
and um
the
the uh
one of the one of the one of the
uh
one man
came up with a question that he could
ask
which was
always a dead giveaway over whether the
other person was really a man or a woman
you know what he would ask them did you
have um
green plastic toy soldiers as a kid yeah
what do you do with them and a woman a
woman trying to be a man would say oh i
lined them up we had wars we had battles
and the man just being announced i
stomped on them
so you know
that's what that's what the turing test
the turing test with computers has
become what's the trick question that's
that's that's why that's right it's sort
of that's
nevertheless conversation not formulated
as a test is a pretty
it's a fascinatingly challenging dance
uh that's a really hard problem to me
conversation when nan poses a test
is a
is a more intuitive illustration how far
away we are from solving intelligence
than like computer vision it's hard
computer vision is harder for me to pull
apart
but with language with conversation you
could see because language is so human
we can we can still clearly
uh
see it
you